la mente es una de las visitas más
emblemáticas del pontificado del papa
francisco y dentro de los últimos 50
años podemos decir que además tiene un
significado político enorme en la zona
de mayor conflictividad que se ha vivido
en los últimos decenios el poder llevar
ahí en el corazón de los conflictos
entre occidente y oriente entre con
implicancias religiosas tan grave
efectivamente una semilla muy potente
muy valiente de llegar a ese territorio
y de poder
enfrentar a los debates que tienen que
ver con los conflictos entre religión y
política bueno ha habido otros intentos
de paz de jerarcas de la iglesia
católica de papas por ir a irak
recordemos que 1999 lo intentó juan
pablo segundo y en 2008 intentó
benedicto 16 que pasó con las vistas
anteriores que no se habían podido dar y
se vuelve la de francisco la primera en
la historia
bueno refleja la inestabilidad sobre
todo del territorio la situación en el
terreno en irak durante los últimos
decenios desde 2003 en adelante ha sido
enormemente compleja poder llegar a
concretar esta visita refleja también
una cierta estabilización de irak y
también unas condiciones de seguridad
mucho mayores pero también unas
condiciones políticas diferentes es
decir hay una disposición política
distinta de las partes para enfrentar un
proceso de cambio donde se puedan
generar condiciones de vía hacia un
tránsito pacífico ante distintas
comunidades que han sido víctimas de
violencia sectaria bueno también vemos
que francisco adelantar a unas reuniones
importantes entre otras con el ayatolá
al máximo representante político
entonces de irak en ese momento y que
esto hace parte una serie de encuentros
interreligiosos que adelantados
francisco durante sus ocho años de
pontificado que representa entonces
estas reuniones con otros jerarcas de la
iglesia de las diferentes religiones en
irak
y poder establecer un diálogo con el
irán el irán chiíta que es el que
representa la mayoría en irak también
tiene un puente con irán es decir hay
ahí hay una estabilización de unas
relaciones que no son solamente señal
para el caso iraquí sino también un
puente hace un diálogo necesario un
cambio de política que debería darse
desde las potencias occidentales hacia e
irán en relación a cambiar la política
de la confrontación hacia una política
de cooperación inteligente o incluso de
poder distender relaciones en función de
intereses comunes reconocimiento
recíproco y posibilidades de
reconstrucción también de vínculos en
vistas de
de generar seguridad la población una
seguridad humana integral que no
solamente atienda a los intereses de los
gobiernos sino también del de la
población más vulnerable y está siendo
altamente dañada por procesos
migratorios de regulados por proceso de
de inseguridad alimentaria a las
víctimas de la posguerra etcétera creo
que ahí hay un elemento muy importante
que la señal del papel francisco
trasciende el ámbito religioso
y entra de lleno estos temas que de la
agenda por decirlo así postran van a
estar desde lleno en el debate mundial